no one's going to denounce the fact that  they tried to lock me up that's what  because every time I'm just holding  stride and it's like I didn't I thought  it was more Malcolm X but I find out I'm  more MLK because as I'm getting hoes  down every day by the press and  financially I'm just standing there and  when when I found out that they tried to  put me in jail it was like a dog was  biting my arm and I I I'm I almost shed  a tear almost but I still walked and  stride through it yeah I think I think  they've been extremely unfair to you who  was they though we can't tell you they  is I'm not using the I don't use the  word as the way I guess you guys use I'm  talking it is them though isn't it I  mean because because when you think  about it consider it  what do I mean like uh uh okay so how  about  are you leaving  are you afraid of the press  he's on